[Musique]
les essentiels du
Sénat patrimoine mondial valoriser
l'expertise culturelle française
entre 2019 et 2022 la commission de la
culture avait conduit des travaux sur la
restitution des biens culturels dans la
continuité elle a souhaité dresser un
état des lieux de l'action de la France
dans le domaine du patrimoine à
internationale à cet effet elle a confié
une mission d'information à LSE Joseph
et Catherine main de sa la mobilisation
de notre savoir-faire en matière de
patrimoine culturel est un outil décisif
pour contrer la perte d'influence de la
France sur la scène
internationale si l'expertise
patrimoniale de la France est solide et
reconnue dans le monde entier c'est
grâce à nos institutions de formation de
renom tel que l'Institut national du
patrimoine l'École du Louvre l'école de
chillot les écoles National Supérieur
d'Architecture et les écoles d'art c'est
aussi grâce à notre engagement
historique dans la coopération
patrimoniale le Louvre Abou Dhabi aux
Émirats Arabes Unis est l'un des
nombreux succès français récents sur le
marché international de l'ingénierie
patrimonial mais pour que la France
puisse pleinement convertir ses atouts
en une politique d'influence et de
rayonnement efficace elle doit parvenir
à répondre de manière coordonnée et
stratégique aux besoins exprimés à
l'échelle
internationale en ce sens les
rapporteurs ont formulé 13
recommandations suivant cinq axes la
commission préconise un pilotage plus
stratégique du dispositif
elle invite à gagner en agilité
opérationnelle
elle recommande d'adapter les moyens au
niveau des ambitions en matière
d'influence par exemple en augmentant le
budget pour les missions archéologiques
et la formation ou encore en renforçant
les équipes dans les établissements
culturels clés parallèlement elle
souhaite faciliter la prospection
notamment en ciblant des zones
géographiques et politiques
stratégiques enfin la mission entend
davantage faire connaître et promouvoir
les savoir-faire français dans les
différents champs du patrimoine à
l'international pour en savoir plus
consultez le site Internet du
Sénat